[Music]
welcome back guys goes on here for anime
uproar and today we are going to be
talking about one of the most powerful
and complex characters in attack on
Titan the beast type he is currently
considered to be the most powerful
time-shifter in the manga he is said to
be the strongest warrior of Marlay and
contrast the captain Levi who has in
turn said to be humanity strongest
soldier so who is this Titan who can
crush the mighty armored Titan without
even breaking a sweat this insanely
powerful Titan has been shrouded in
mystery from the beginning but today
we'll be looking at everything you need
to know about this unique and deadly
Titan if you're new to the channel be
sure to subscribe because there are many
more attack on Titan videos on the way a
quick warning there will be manga
spoilers so proceed with extreme caution
if you are still with me let's begin
with the secret identity of the beast
Titan the current possessor of the Beast
Titan is Zeke Yeager he is the older
half-brother of our protagonist Eren
Yeager and the son of Grisha and Deena
fritz as you can probably tell by the
last name Deena was a member of the
royal family and as a result Zeke has
royal blood in his veins too Zeke is 25
years old by the year 850 and 29 years
old
after the time-skip he currently only
has one year or less left to live before
he has to pass the beast Titan power on
to Colt in the manga because of Amir's
curse which guarantees that no Titan
shifter can live beyond 13 years now
before we break down to these Titan
specific abilities let's look back at
Zeke's very interesting past Zeke was
born in Marley to LDN parents Grisha and
Deena the LD ins were and continue to be
discriminated against in Marley in most
cases they are forced to live in
designated areas and are treated with
extreme cruelty because of their ability
to turn into titans they are treated as
monsters by the marlane people Grisha
and his sister traveled beyond the wall
aka beyond a designated LD in territory
when they were kids as a result his
sister was taken by a soldier and ripped
apart by dogs for his amusement Grisha
would probably have also been killed in
a gruesome manner if the LD in spy known
as the owl had
rescues him after this event Grizzard
developed a deep-seated hatred for the
Marlon government and eventually joined
the LDN restorationist a group of LD
ants who sought to overthrow the Marlon
government and restore LD and power
Risha eventually married Deena a member
of the royal LD n family that did not
follow the first king Fritz to the
island of paradise where he used the
founding Tyson power also known as the
coordinate to build the three walls and
erase the memory of the LD n people so
that they would forget about Marley and
come to believe that they were the last
remnants of humanity in a world overrun
by Titans the LD n restoration has
viewed the king as a traitor because he
abandoned the conflict with Marley and
as a result left the rest of the LD ins
to suffer under the oppression of the
Marlon people the restorationist knew
that in order to restore LD n power they
would need to acquire this power the
power of the founding Titan by the way
if you want to know more about the
coordinate and the founding Titan power
check out the coordinate explained video
which I'll leave in the description
eventually Grisha and Deena had a kid
and named him Zeke some years later the
Marlon government was looking for LD and
kids because they needed them to use the
seven Titan powers they had stolen from
the LD n people remember only Ella
beings could become Titans or Titan
shifters without LD n warriors the
Marlon government could not harness any
of the nine Titan powers Grisha then got
an idea he would hand Zeke his son over
to the Marlon government and make him an
LD n mole however to his surprise
Zeke betrayed him the young Zeke was
brainwashed by the Malayan government
and ratted out his parents who were then
arrested and taken to the island of
paradise where they were both supposed
to be turned into mindless Titans
although Grisha obviously escaped that
fate
thanks to Aaron Kruger the owl what is
unclear though is whether or not Grisha
and Deena told Zeke about his royal
blood in the manga it is clear that the
Marlon government had no idea that Deena
or Zeke were members of the royal LD n
family but the real question is does eek
know and is he keeping this secret that
information may come into play later in
the manga so Zeke became the perfect
Marlon warrior he eventually acquired
the beast Titan power and made his way
through the ranks
until he eventually earned the title of
war tree the highest and most honored
position any LDN can hope to get in the
Marlin nation another thing that other
characters find surprising is
high-ranking male officials seem to take
zieks advice and thoughts seriously when
thinking about what to do next
both Reiner and Bertolt reported to him
and together they all went to the island
of paradise to take the coordinate power
for the merlion government it is clear
that Bertolt and Reiner look up to him
because Amir notices that they look at
the beast Titan like excited children
when they spot him at boot guard castle
on the island of paradise where the main
attack on Titan story takes place the
beast Titan as we know caused many
problems for the survey Corps he defeats
one of the strongest and most eccentric
soldiers in the survey Corps BK
effortlessly really he turns the people
of Connie's village into Titans and
commands Titans to attack the survey
corps at would guard castle he also
plans the final assault on the survey
corps at the Battle of shegaon Shiina
district he almost defeats the survey
corps but while he is throwing chunks of
stones at groups of soldiers that are
charging at him and shooting smoke
flares he is caught off guard by Levi
and almost killed
however peak a fellow Titan shifter and
Marlin warrior saves him in the nick of
time in her Titan form which is called
Cartman Zeke stops to tell heir and his
half-brother that they were both victims
of grisha's brainwashing and that he
will come back to save him before
escaping back to marlane afterwards the
male Mideast war begins
Zeke fights with the other Titan
shifters working for the Marlin
government but is almost killed again
this time by anti Titan artillery
however Reiner using his power of the
armored Titan shields him from the blast
Zeke was a formidable and frightening
opponent now recognises that
technological advancements are beginning
to eclipse even his power he also
revealed in the newer chapters of the
manga that he is actually scared of the
Ackerman clan and hopes that he never
has to fight Levi again it's interesting
seeing him arguably the most powerful
Titan shifter scared for once by the
power of one of our main characters when
this whole time
it was the Titans and especially the
Beast sight and were portrayed as the
scary ones nevertheless Zeke wants to go
back to parodies and capture to
coordinate as soon as possible because
his time is running out as mentioned due
to Amir's curse he only has one year
left before he has to pass on his powers
to warrior cadet Colt Grice and the next
possessor is unlikely to be as powerful
as eek it is acknowledged that Zeke has
powers that previous possessors didn't
and people are curious as to why that is
but the audience knows that is probably
related to the fact that he has royal
blood also the new chapter chapter 94
recently came out and I did a review for
it linked in the description in this
manga chapter we see that Zeke is still
close to his Marlin fearing grandparents
Krishna's parents and visits them at the
internment Zone the Vario when he gets
the chance that's all we know about Zeke
so far although I can't wait to see what
happens with him next now let's get into
the beast I need special abilities it is
important to note that some of these
special abilities are specific to Zeke
and have not been possessed by previous
beast titans such as his ability to
change humans into titans it is
important to mention Zeke's excellent
control of his Titan form he always
retains his human mind in Titan form
unlike Aaron and he can even speak
fluently and for extended periods of
time in his Titan form that is not
possible for any other Titan shifters
except peek in her Titan form and Amir
and even a mere a very skilled Titan
shifter and an exception to the rule can
only utter a word or two at a time
Zeke speaks to humans but also gives
orders to other Titans which they
usually follow if they were created by
his own spinal fluid although as the
incident with me K and the Titan that
was holding him revealed the control
isn't perfect like the founding Titans
control would be in theory like all
titans Zeke has superhuman regeneration
after Levi nearly kills him Sheik is
shown talking to Aaron and his face is
already partially healed like a knee
Zeke is also able to harden his Titan
body and he tries to harden the nape of
his neck when Levi attacks him but the
ability needs time to work and Levi
proves to be too fast for him also like
rider has shown it appears that other
Titans can transfer their brain activity
to the rest of their nervous system
while also using the Titans brain in
order
to survive having their head cut off he
also possesses immense strength and is
able to break off chunks of the wall and
hurl them accurately from extremely far
distances he seems to be a fan of
baseball since he refers to his Boulder
tosses as pitches and says he's hoping
for a perfect game in the Battle of
shegaon Shiina he also seems to be a
formidable fighter since he was able to
defeat the armored Titan without showing
any visible sign of injury or fatigue
himself lastly his most impressive
ability is his ability to transform
humans into titans that will obey his
commands Zeke possesses a scream that he
can use while a human form to transform
humans that have been injected with his
spinal fluid in two titans unlike
regular titans these Titans have been
able to move at night but hanji
speculates that they can only move under
a full moon
and speaking of hungry you guys might
find it interesting to know that Zeke
and hungie were tied for smartest
character in the official attack on
titan guidebook both scoring 11 out of
10 this says a lot about the current
beast times mental prowess but this is
yet another trait which cannot be passed
down so that is what we know so far
about Zeke and about the beast titans
unique abilities however for me Zeke is
still a bit of an enigma what does he
mean when he says he will rescue Aaron
is he really the obedient unquestioning
marilaine warrior that he appears to be
or is this hairy genius hiding something
Zeke's name is a shortened form for
Ezekiel which is Hebrew for God will
strengthen in the Bible Ezekiel was a
prophet among the Hebrews exiled to
Babylon who prophesized destruction of
Jerusalem and Israel's restoration could
this be a complete coincidence or will
Zeke actually have a part to play in LDS
restoration hmm
I personally wouldn't be surprised if
there is more to Zeke than it seems at
the moment let me know what you guys
think about Zeke in the comment section
below I would love to hear your thoughts
what is he planning anyways guys if you
made it all the way to the end you rock
thank you so much for watching if you
enjoyed this video be sure to go beast
mode on that like button and subscribe
for more attack on Titan videos you can
also check out our attack on Titan
playlist on the left of your screen if
you want to see more videos like this
consider supporting us on patreon link
in the description
until next time see you space cowboys
[Music]
[Applause]